So Adam Levine right got in a little
trouble
um with uh this hole they're basically
basically yeah there's a throat
basically he had a side throat and uh
and I could not believe that he actually
[ __ ] her based on what she said when
she came out and there's a video that we
could play it but I it doesn't even
matter yeah who wants to listen to her
exactly get out of here exactly so she
came out and she was like uh yeah so
basically I was having an affair with
Adam Levine and I need to get ahead of
the story because my friend was trying
to send [ __ ] uh the the screenshots
to TMZ my friend was ahead uh yeah good
she also has the [ __ ] only fans I
don't trust a single thing that a girl
with an only fan says okay there's gotta
be one girl that could lead me to go
look at her [ __ ] what do you mean oh if
she's like doing something to stir up
you potentially being curious Yeah so
basically she said they had an affair I
don't know if they had an affair what
costume is an affair that's what I'm
saying he could have clapped cheeks but
if his wife is okay with that not an
affair it's only an affair yeah if
you're doing it behind your wife's back
and there's an emotional day if he's
gotten head and that's not unfair even
if it's emotional she allows you to be
emotional that's totally fine yeah right
yeah yeah according to the throat yeah
she said uh he told her that he's
leaving his wife
and he's been leaving his wife for like
the past move it three let them
screenshots I think that wasn't he was
like oh it's complicated and also he
might have been leaving her ass
they could have been having problems
because this is the months later two
months later she might be leaving him
now but I mean yeah that's where it's
from you left a lot of evidence if she
wants if she wants that money yeah
yeah like we're gonna get to the wife
thing but like I feel bad for him
imagine imagine
being married to a Victoria's Secret
model yep I'm not talking about a
weekend throat I'm talking about every
morning you gotta wake up Sunday morning
right like you got to wake up she's got
that stupid Brazilian is she Brazilian
no she's like she's like African Belgian
or some [ __ ] right oh thank God [ __ ]
thank God he was South Africa namibian
interview oh she's from Namibia yeah
she's an namibian bro
she's namibian is she black
black queen
she might be she's a light-skinned black
woman that's a name that she's not
saying she's light-skinned that's a
light skin Arielle to look like her
behind me oh my God I thought that [ __ ]
was Brazilian dude that's an African
sound of name dude I'll be honest with
you can I just say one thing before we
move on just from this I think if a
girl's voice is below a certain decibel
you should be able to cheat
like every one of these Brazilians
baritone like the voice is crazy yeah
yeah I love you sweetheart
yeah what should we do this weekend
what should we do this week do you think
it's biological or that's like a social
thing why are they all have such low
voices God can't give you everything
yeah yeah that's that's a great that's
what it is perspective exactly why don't
they try to get a different voice like a
BBL for your throat yes yeah that's
smart actually someone write that down
yes yeah they could do that uh be a
throw BBL yeah just a little voice lift
a little voice lift I think a voiceless
we actually I mean it sounds crazy with
it we're insulting them that's that's
not fair and she's probably going
through a really tough time and she's a
black queen and she's not Brazilian son
and she's not Brazilian though she's a
black queen she's from Brazilians from
Southwest Africa that's now okay she's
in a baby Queen she's an African Queen
him she's an African queen but I think
Dutch actually or some [ __ ] somebody
she's a colonizer colonizer
what about the shark he probably dragged
her ass down there oh cause she's a
victim that's a good point of
colonization he's also a victim of a
colonizer yeah that's it also she's 511
walk around a jungle
do you know what I'm saying
it's dangerous to be fine the pygmies
are like five feet yeah yeah those are
the people who could Thrive you know
what they do to albinos over there what
do they do they use the
that's what she survived exactly she ran
away from that I respect her 100
so just to get back
basically the reason why Adam Levine did
some crazy [ __ ] is because he said to
the side throat that he was gonna name
his newborn baby with his wife after her
he was thinking about the craziest [ __ ]
that's a wild boy that's the craziest
[ __ ] that's hard to defend and I've
tried so we know to name your daughter
after her throat is crazy this is your
defense you really believe moves like
Jagger dude smash a Texas gutter rat and
said he wanted a name his newborn after
come on which is which is
strongest
which is very clearly in his screenshots
yo can we name our kid Sumner dead
serious
y'all really believe that come on but I
thought he said that
this is what I thought I thought that
they never smashed it was faked him no
no I thought it was real DMS but I
thought they never smashed and he was
just being flirted like I thought he was
just like an insecure dude that like
needs girls to like say he's great like
all these [ __ ] that's where
everybody's entertainment they thought
that and then the other messages were
you look that much hotter in person like
it's still the same [ __ ] and then he
complimented himself which was vile
I love that he goes you look so much
better in person it's crazy and so do I
[Laughter]
um and you guys know 2004 he was the one
that uh Jessica Simpson cheated on Nick
Lachey with oh [ __ ] her people hurt
people bro oh no oh [ __ ] oh no Behati
Prince low DM's got to be crazy right
now dude too bad she's full of [ __ ]
turning into a human I don't know what
that is
his African wife dude you don't know
what that is that is the worst time to
chew on your wife when she's pregnant
because she can't even cheat back bro
she gotta wait yeah you can can you
though yeah how many weeks my boy's
brother used to smash it right here
chick bro and he said he had an arm and
a leg in that kid
yeah that's facts that's a true ass
story yeah it's a way more rehearsal
Parkway
that's way more hurtful yeah but
spraying on someone else's seed dude
that's nuts that's crazy but he called
it fertilizer
yo he's like yeah yo it is sometimes you
got a mulch landscape a little all right
guys we're gonna take a break from this
exclusive patreon clip because I gotta
tell you all about the best wallets in
the business damn right okay you know
what's happening you're walking down the
street some dude's bumping into you and
he's stealing all your information you
don't even realize it they don't got to
steal your wallet to steal your
information you know you pay for a
coffee you just tap your phone on the
thing someone could tap your thigh or
your back pocket while you're walking
down the street steal all your [ __ ] and
not if you got an extra extra got the
RFID protection it protects you against
Boop steal all your information okay the
best wallet in the business look how
cool they got this nice little leather
one you can even put that little what is
that thing called miles of air or
something
air tag you can even air tag it so you
never have to lose it I'm telling you
this is the best in the business it's
trackable worldwide this is the one
while you will not lose okay you're not
gonna lose the wallet and nobody's gonna
take what's in it from you and it's a
no-brainer because you're getting up to
20 off site wide when you use the code
flagrant at extra.com so check out the
wallets at extra
ekster.com and get up to 20 off site
wide with the code flagrant now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
and join the [ __ ] Army at patreon.com
flagrant2 so let's say he's allowed to
cheat he's allowed to have side [ __ ]
but he really cheated when he was going
to name the kid after that's insane
to be dog yeah
your kid after people you want them to
be like imma name you after a throat
yeah what do you tell your son maybe she
was really talented
but he's just your son that's not your
daughter dude
yeah there's no way son there's no way
she's good
I've seen her I've seen her there's no
way she's good why she's too attractive
nah uh no so what what is it then say
what what is it then because if you
gonna name if I'm gonna name my son
after some chick amazing
the head is amazing everything that is
so soft that's weird that's like boy
named Sushi that's Johnny can't be my
girl but I wouldn't do it yo naming your
son after a girl who's back used to
blowout is so wild bro
he's a wild boy
bro he does have moves like Mick Jagger
bro he got a wild boy dance moves yeah I
mean like oh come on bro listen the girl
is nah she's she's a starfish
a starfish exactly sometimes you could
tell yeah even in the video she's like I
was taken advantage of or not like no
girl that gives crazy head says
something like that oh yeah there was a
girl they did a whole little expose
taking up all of her old DMS or all her
old tick tocks she was posing tick tocks
like three months ago being like life is
so crazy and then playing a Maroon 5
song No and then her mom and her sister
both commented OMG the song choice so
that it doesn't indicate remorse to me
someone else also pointed out in her
accusation she never once was like I
made a mistake I apologize I like was
banging some dude that had a wife and
she didn't know for this [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
she's playing the video yeah she goes
and then she actually called herself out
on this in another video
I know but uh
come on bro come on how you got my
Instagram it's not everybody
looking at my unread DMS and there was a
one that someone looked at I know I
didn't look at it oh yeah
no it won't start side bucket you looked
at her [ __ ] message I would never
look I was doing recon for you okay
bro I know I'm married Bro yeah I might
be looking for a name for our kid or
something I ain't doing nothing yeah
yo what is worse like this is a good
question that we should ask women uh
Dove what what would you rather would
you rather
would you rather your boyfriend [ __ ]
another person or name your kid after
another person
I think [ __ ]
[ __ ] right yeah I think girls are more
offended by emotional cheating Than
Physical cheating
yeah that's my hot tape and guys are the
opposite yes yeah yeah
what I believe I agree with you because
it wasn't a hot tape
I'll say yeah you talk to one woman who
was like yeah
I know right yeah
I'm a feminist bro oh is that what it's
called yeah yeah you're allowed to teach
as long as it's not emotional
what is the term for when you're just
like an ugly girl and you have those
views that match that
died
yo why do Brazilians sound like
feminists okay stop
that is that God is just playing jokes
like we're gonna make the hottest women
ever but they're gonna sound like
they're from Portland have you ever what
about that other one Lima something like
that
Adriana Lima yeah oh she's so beautiful
crazy boys it's crazy I don't know that
for a fact
maybe that's just God's way of telling
them not to talk oh [ __ ] you know what I
mean yo this is your biggest obstacle in
life is you talking so let's just make
you not want to do that yo what what's
going on right now this is her voice
Adriana I was afraid to miscommunicate
something so I do not talk a lot
the fantasy bra yeah
every Angel wants to wear it and every
year they come up with different designs
that's not ideal yeah it's fun to make
fun of hot chicks yeah I really couldn't
care less
okay my question to you is why can't you
believe Adam Levine cheated
is dependent
no I think he broke her back there's no
question but why but I don't know that
his wife is not okay with it that's what
I'm trying to say but why would you
assume that his wife is okay isn't it
weird that he said well because he's a
[ __ ] rock star Mark that none on him
but like I don't know they have a bunch
of kids his wife's skill in this world
is walking straight and not falling his
skill in this world is being one of the
most famous singers ever okay so he
might have a little bit more leverage
and uh what if he didn't leverage it
what if he was like I'm a good guy at
how this works what if he didn't
leverage it what if he was like yo I'm
truthful to you we got kids you're the
mother of my babies I'm not going I
respect the [ __ ] out of him for that and
then he stepped out why is that
unbelievable too no no I'm not saying
it's not believable that could have
happened it absolutely could have
happened what I'm saying is we don't
know their relationship so I can't say
he's a cheater yet
come on
yeah and I'll be honest that first
tweet's probably wrong
how about the last one go down to the
last one that being said if maroon boy
he's even dumber than I thought
well I never expect these guns to be an
intelligent you know what I mean like
he's dming these side pieces like why
would you even leave a trace see that's
the thing I bet you if they had an
agreement she was like oh don't
embarrass me and what he did was
embarrassing exactly so therefore he
broke the agreement oh no Virgo cheating
no no let me be very clear about what
I'm saying please oh yeah because I
don't think you're getting it on this
one case
might be okay for his wife we don't know
we haven't spoken to her right I would
love to I would love to speak to her me
too I would love to speak to her as well
yeah where is she getting another ring
added to her [ __ ] necklace or
something like that
come on don't we know about the culture
yeah listen when David Cho discovered
his wife when he was walking in the in
the middle of the Congo all these years
ago searching for a dinosaur yes do you
remember that story
it was a crazy story he was like I
brought back two things
AIDS and and uh uh prinslow uh the
hottie
but yeah you know what I mean the names
are reverse it's like Mandarin yeah
exactly okay so what I'm saying is
having sex with other women might be
allowed by the wife yeah
naming their child after one of them is
not allowed or publicly humiliating her
is not allowed so that is where the
breach of trust has happened but we
don't know for a fact that she's not
cool with him smashing other people
she's from Africa maybe there's multiple
wives situation in their culture we're
not sure yeah that is interesting that's
a possibility yeah
come on a lot of us just found out that
exists
anything that's a good name neighbor
Namibia I like name my son Namibia yeah
that's a great deal why do you think
that he want to name his son
after the girl well summoner's kind of a
gender-neutral name and he was just
having a boy and he's like all right
about a bing there we go
why would you ask permission
what you gotta ask permission for no you
got an expiration why you got it why
well you could just say oh it's not
after you it's happened
because he's just trying to stay on her
good side so she don't blow him and blow
him up that's what the whole thing
backfired nah that's all we're fixing it
supposedly it backfired because one of
her
ugly friends was gonna sell it to us oh
calm the [ __ ] off just give him nobody
believes that give them money give them
money yeah it's not that hard you give
them money and then they feel guilty
because they've accepted the money don't
give them presents cash yeah
cash yeah yeah yeah it can't even be it
can't even be a wire here's for your
flights Mr Beast video a suitcase
[Laughter]
yeah exactly no because what happens is
once you accept the cash you understand
the it's a business transaction it's a
business transaction you understand the
arrangement if they don't accept the
cash then you got some friction and it
is what it is but they can't even call
you out what are they gonna say he tried
to pay me for being a throw that's a
Stormy Daniels [ __ ] she came out she got
paid keep her mouth shut and then she
started talking she should be in jail I
agree with that no I think that 100
believe me stormy for prison storms for
prison
her more than Hillary lock that [ __ ] I
think we said this last episode it's
like oh I banged Donald Trump not Mr
President
so now it's different no no that NBA
uh-uh that's what I'm saying uh-uh this
ain't a stop just because my [ __ ] went
up don't mean your [ __ ] goes up Pam we
agreed
you hit her off you put 10 000 on the on
the on the she probably don't even have
furniture put it on the windowsill or
some [ __ ] like that yeah she got a
roommate to put in the freezer yeah put
ten thousand yeah hey there you go in
case you need anything yeah say some
[ __ ] like that if she accepts it she can
never say a word again she she will but
she can can't why can't she what is the
law yeah yeah inside
it's an internal it's what's the oldest
business what's the oldest yeah this is
funny he thinks he thinks throat have
ethics
I have ethics he doesn't want it to be
added that she's accepted money for sex
because once she accepts money for sex
her value
man hold on you both are saying things
at the same time she's already outed
herself for sleeping with a married man
she's already said I'm kind of a piece
of [ __ ] I slept with a guy who was
married to a woman who's pregnant and I
didn't care is there no
um
recourse for this there should be some
recourse for both of them
but what more for him but some for him
no he was
crazy for the name and the kid thing I
mean [ __ ] bunkers it's not
mind-boggling that he might have had you
know some side [ __ ] right it's not the
craziest yeah you're a rock star I get
it Rockstar's rappers NBA athletes it
might happen and your wife is like okay
yeah what do you think not the best it's
horrible it's [ __ ] up you should have
made me look like an idiot and you
shouldn't have done it with only fans
girls I mean what are you doing dude
their whole business is publicity well
here's the thing this is why they need
it so the only fans girls get a spike
initially yeah right because people like
oh I want to see some titties and then
once all the followers realize it's the
same titties every single month you're
like oh I don't need that right right
there's nothing new so what you have to
do is you have to start going a little
bit crazier in order to maintain the
money yeah it's like YouTube titles yeah
I mean so the crazy exactly so the
crazier it gets means okay now I'm gonna
show titties okay now I'm gonna show
[ __ ] after you show titties and [ __ ]
okay now I'm doing masturbation video
eventually you're sucking dick you're a
porn star I've been actually that's just
how it goes so this in my opinion is her
trying to not [ __ ] ah because the whole
thing is clout the more famous she gets
the more people sign up without her
sucking dick
but it's gonna buy her what two three
months before everybody's like oh same
titties yeah but then
for three more months yeah because I
wanted to go look
I went to Reddit obviously and
her broke ass wasn't even on Reddit
that's how you notice it's not even
worth it but if Reddit hasn't taken your
porn yeah and put it up for free for the
good people you're not popping bro did
you search for it or you asked somebody
to search for it
yeah
I'll find it immediately I'll find it in
one moment I figured out how to do the
note though
that was fire of me oh yeah that was
impressive yeah I figured my whole phone
out and you guys did nothing are you not
allowed to name your kid after a girl
you smash
what are the names fire yeah what's the
rule on that how can it be fire dude
what does she do with it well the only
fans the name could just be objectively
cool yeah like what Striker
Xena
that's a sickness Xena is a cool name
[Laughter]
to you yeah